The next principle is Robert Martin's dependency inversion principle,
which we have seen in an earlier lesson. It says that high level modules should
not depend upon low level modules. Both should instead depend upon abstractions.
This is related to inversion of control, in which normally abstraction framework
classes would make use of concrete client classes. It is the opposite to
the way that modules are structured in traditional layered architectures.
Stated another way, Martin is saying that our layering should be one of
abstraction, rather than one of control or data access. Doing so
will lead to designs in which the controlling principles are enforced at
the highest levels of our architecture